Guten Morgen, Linus. Ich kann dir sagen, mein Bedarf an schlechten Nachrichten ist gedeckt. Ich hoffe, das ändert sich jetzt langsam. Lalalalalala, Logbuch Netzpolitik. Die 98. Ausgabe haben wir jetzt schon. Und grüßen Tim und Linus, hallo. Und ja, jetzt machen wir mal Schluss mit schlechten Nachrichten. Und ja, wir machen es ganz kurz, nämlich wir haben uns den Spezialisten für gute Nachrichten eingeladen. Thomas Lohninger und nach Konsum der Folge, was war denn unsere gemeinsame Folge noch mal? War das die 96, 95? Weiß grad nicht. 96 war es. Ja, da hast du ja schon ausführlich Einblicke gegeben in Linus Abwesenheit, in dein neues Engagement bei der IDRI in Brüssel. Und da zeichnete sich ja schon ab, dass wir dann in den folgenden Wochen, also den jetzt zurückliegenden Wochen, in die heiße Phase treten werden, rund um die Abstimmung über Netzneutralität auf europäischer Ebene, also für das Europäische Parlament zumindest.
Ja, und du hast ja schon gesagt, wir haben was zu feiern, weil ich konnte selber nicht glauben, dass es wirklich passiert ist, aber wir haben gewonnen. Gestern hat das Europäische Parlament eine Verordnung zur Netzneutralität erlassen und das was da drin steht, das kann man auch wirklich Netzneutralität nennen. Also das ist wirklich ein Schutz für das Internet von einer halben Milliarde Menschen, das da nicht mehr drin diskriminiert werden darf und Provider ihre Macht über das Netzwerk nicht ausnutzen dürfen.
Aber ich dachte, die Auguren haben sich ihre Köpfe zusammengeschlossen und haben beschlossen, das Dunkle über die Welt zu bringen. Und überhaupt der Widerstand gegen die Lobby ist unmöglich. Was ist passiert?
Gegen diesen ständigen Behauptungen, dass das Brüssel so lobbygetrieben ist, man kann da auch wirklich ohne Geldkoffer mit guten Argumenten wahnsinnig viel bewegen. Also es ist wirklich der Erfolg, den wir jetzt haben, der zeigt deutlich, dass es möglich ist, auf einer sachlichen Ebene mit den Leuten zu argumentieren. Und man muss natürlich politisch handeln, aber der Erfolg jetzt, das war perfekte asymmetrische Kriegsführung, weil wir hatten wahrscheinlich ein Tausendstel des Budgets der Telco-Industrie auf der anderen Seite und die Kommission hatte so einen schönen Plan, wie das Ganze passieren soll. Und am Ende ist es doch ganz anders gekommen. Also das zeigt schon, dass man, wenn man eine gute Kampagne hat, wenn man die richtigen Leute hat und vor allem auch das, was idri tut, ist meiner Meinung nach beispiellos, zumindest in Europa. Dieses professionelle Level an Lobbying habe ich selber noch nie gesehen. Und ich habe auch hier wirklich viel gelernt über dieses Handwerk. Ich glaube, deswegen haben wir das gewonnen, natürlich aber auch, weil wir diese große Kampagne hatten mit ganz ganz vielen Leuten, die das zum Thema gemacht haben.
Bevor wir vielleicht noch mal auf die Arbeit von idri eingehen, würde ich gerne noch mal kurz so das, was jetzt tatsächlich geschehen ist, noch mal ganz kurz beschrieben bekommen. Also es stand ja an, die Entscheidung über Netzneutralität im ITRE Ausschuss, dem federführenden Ausschuss für diese Geschichte und dem Nachfolgen die Abstimmung im Parlament.
Genau, ich glaube unsere Sendung war ein bisschen vor der Abstimmung im I3, also im Industrieausschuss.
Genau, dann wurde auch noch ein bisschen verschoben und so.
Genau, genau, genau. Das wurde ja irgendwie zwei Wochen nach hinten verschoben und dann war da irgendwie ein irrsinnig kurzer Zeitplan. Also normalerweise hat man da mindestens eineinhalb Monate zwischen dem federführenden Ausschuss und der großen Plenumsabstimmung, damit sich alle das auch noch mal durchlesen können. In diesem Fall hatten wir zwei Wochen und die Abstimmung im Industrieausschuss, die haben wir verloren. Da haben die Konservativen sich durchgesetzt mit den Stimmen der Liberalen und da war halt einfach für uns nichts zu machen. Das hat sich intern aber auch schon abgezeichnet. Eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger eine Woche davor war uns klar, das kriegen wir nicht mehr gebogen. Die haben ihre Leute eingeschworen. Wir haben da auch Geschichten gehört, dass Nelikus persönlich lobbyiert und da war einfach keine Möglichkeit für uns, eine gute Entscheidung hinzubekommen. Und wir haben uns dann aber ja auch schon im Vorhinein auf das Plenum konzentriert. Und weil wir gewusst haben, da haben wir wieder neue Abgeordnete, da schaut es auch anders aus, weil der Industrieausschuss ist schon ein bisschen industrional, wie man sich vielleicht denken könnte. Und ja, dann im Plenum haben wir es wirklich noch gedreht bekommen.
Aber normalerweise gilt ja die Erwartungshaltung, dass was der federführende Ausschuss als Grundsatzentscheidung fällt, das wird in der Regel auch auf europäischer Ebene, also auf Parlaments-Ebene dann angenommen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich so die Regel. Nur, wenn man eine Sache hier in Brüssel lernt, ist dann everything is possible. Also es gibt so gut wie keine Regel, die man nicht brechen kann und die unmöglichsten Dinge passieren. Und es war aber jetzt auch so, dass wir die vorherigen Ausschüsse alle gewonnen haben eigentlich, dass da überall gute Netzvertralität beschlossen wurde und alle Reparaturen an der Verordnungsvorschlag der Kommission vorgenommen wurden, die man braucht, damit das keine Schlupflöcher mehr hat. Nur im Industrieausschuss war das anders. Dadurch hatten wir auch ein bisschen ein anderes Verhältnis, weil klar war irgendwie so, ok, hier gibt es nicht nur eine Meinung, auf die sich alle einigen können, sondern das war ein Ausschuss, der ist vielleicht der federführende, aber es gibt da durchaus auch noch ganz andere Einstellungen, weil die Konservativen haben jetzt auch irgendwie, man hatte ja Mehrheiten in den anderen Ausschüssen für diese Reparaturen. Wichtig ist nur, also der federführende Ausschuss, da gibt es ja auch die Berichterstatterin, Pilar del Castillo, die Konservative von Spanien, die bleibt jetzt auch an diesem Dossier dran. Die wird jetzt auch nach der Plenumsabstimmung das Mandat behalten, wenn sie wiedergewählt wird und tritt dann in Verhandlungen mit dem Rat, aber nicht vorgreifen. Also wir haben auf jeden Fall jetzt im Plenum das wirklich geschafft, indem wir auch wirklich eine Koalition hatten, wo auch Konsumentenschützer, Zivilgesellschaft und Teile der Industrie, vor allem auch Content Provider, sich auf die Beine gestellt haben. Wir hatten ganz viele Start-ups, die sich dann noch in letzter Minute dem Kampf angeschlossen haben. Start-ups von Net Neutrality kann man vielleicht erwähnen, wenn wir auch verlinken, wer irgendwie ein Unternehmen hat, was irgendwas mit Internet zu tun hat. Egal, ob Online-Dienste oder Einzelhandel, der kann sich dort irgendwie in diese Allianz aufnehmen lassen, weil die wollen halt auch zeigen, dass es in der Wirtschaft Interesse gibt für Netzneutralität. Weil die Gegenseite argumentiert ja immer so, das sind nur die Linken, das sind die Kommunisten, das sind die Anarchisten, die Netzneutralität haben wollen und vergessen dabei, dass das ja eigentlich auch im Wettbewerb geht.
So, das heißt ITRE wurde verloren und dann stand jetzt die Abstimmung im Parlament an. Du hast ja schon gesagt, da war dann alles gut, aber letztlich gab es ja auch nur eine Abstimmung. Das heißt, da muss sich ja quasi die Gesetzesvorlage, über die abgestimmt wird, dann noch signifikant geändert haben.
Also es war so, in der Woche vor der Abstimmung war die Deadline- für Änderungsanträge und der erste Schritt für uns war einfach mal zu schauen, wie kriegt man gute Änderungsanträge getebert von einer möglichst großen Mehrheit an Parteien im Europaparlament. Und da war es zum Glück so, dass wir recht früh, weil wir auch eben, es gab recht schnell einen gemeinsamen Text, auf den sich alle einigen konnten. Und das war auch ein Text, wo wir darauf geschaut haben, dass die gesamte Zivilgesellschaft dem zustimmen kann, dass der wirklich wasserdicht ist. Und diese Textarbeit war eigentlich der Schlüssel für den Erfolg. Das hätte niemand damit gerechnet, wahrscheinlich, dass man das schafft, in so kurzer Zeit noch mal so einen großen Sprung zu machen. Aber dieser Text, den wir jetzt abgestimmt haben, füllt so grob drei Kriterien. Einerseits ist er wahnsinnig minimalistisch, also er ändert wirklich nur ganz wenige Wörter. Er versucht eben wirklich jede Diskriminierung auszuschließen, egal ob im Netzwerk oder auch preisliche Diskriminierung über die Ausnahme von Volumensgrenzen.
Also er ändert wenig Wörter an was an der ursprünglichen Vorlage oder?
An dem Text der Industrieausschuss abgestimmt. Ja, um einfach sozusagen den Schritt möglichst klein zu machen. Und er vermeidet auch, das dritte Kriterium war, die Leute eben, dass man schaut, dass man politisch aufgeladene Begriffe vermeidet. Und das, was ich jetzt beschlossen habe.
Was sind das für Begriffe jetzt?
Es wurde ganz lange an den anderen Ausschüssen über Sachen abgestimmt, zum Beispiel, dass Specialized Services nicht funktional ident sein dürfen zu Online-Services. Das war einer der größten Kritikpunkte. Es war für uns als Zivilgesellschaft eigentlich auch immer das, was wir gefordert haben, dass es da eben, dass du eben nicht Video-on-Demand-Dienst machen kannst als Specialized Service, wenn es sowas auch im Internet gibt, weil wenn es es das im Best-Effort-Internet gibt, wozu soll dann Specialized Service gut sein? Es braucht keine Bevorzugung und wir haben jetzt irgendwie dieselbe, denselben Sinn erreicht, aber mit anderen Wörtern und ja, ich kann da gerne in Details gehen. Ich bin ein großer Freund von Netzvertralitätsgesetzen, wie manche vielleicht wissen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das in die Show passt.
Also es wurde erstmal, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, gesagt, okay, der gesamte Internetverkehr muss gleich und ohne Diskriminierung, Einschränkung oder Störung, unabhängig von Absender, Empfänger, Art, Inhalt, Gerät, Dienst oder Anwendung behandelt werden. Das ist schon mal, das ist glaube ich, klarer kann man Netzneutralität nicht definieren. Dann gibt es die specialized services, wo gesagt wird, okay, man kann spezielle Inhalte an Anwendung oder andere Dienste optimieren, aber nur über logisch getrennte Kapazitäten und mit strenger Zugangskontrolle. Keine Ahnung, warum jetzt noch strenger Zugangskontrolle beisteht. Bei ausreichenden Netzkapazitäten und sie müssen Funktionen enthalten, die durchgehend verbesserte Qualitätsmerkmale erfordern. Und dann gibt es eben dieses Verbot, was du gerade schon sagtest, nicht als Ersatz oder bessere, also nicht als Ersatz für gängige Internetzugangsdienste. Das wäre dann also, wenn ich das richtig lese, ist doch sogar dieser, diese Telekom-Spotify-Deals und weiß nicht, E plus macht das ja auch mit irgendwie MTV Music oder so. Die sind doch jetzt eigentlich erledigt, oder? Oder ist die Frage, weil hier steht ja nur, der Traffic soll behandelt werden, wie jeder andere auch. Jetzt steht halt nicht, ob er abgerechnet werden soll, wie jeder andere auch. Bleibt diese Lücke offen?
Ne, das haben wir in Artikel 23, Paragraph 5 geregelt, wo einfach klar ein Diskriminierungsverbot drin ist, das auch losgelöst ist von den Vertragsbedingungen. Das heißt, du kannst auch nicht mehr über AGBs diskriminieren und es darf einfach keine Unterscheidung mehr vom Provider zwischen Diensten gemacht werden, sofern diese Funktionalequivalent sind. Das Funktionalequivalent findet sich dann in Artikel 23,2 und damit hast du theoretisch immer noch die Möglichkeit, dass du sagst, ich priorisiere jetzt in meinem Netzwerk Voice-over-IP, aber wenn, dann muss ich alle Voice-over-IP-Anbieter, Protokolle und whatever auch gleich behandeln und genauso priorisieren. Das selber gilt für Video- und Demand- Dienste, wenn ich da was priorisieren will. Wenn ich da was vom Volumen ausnehmen will, dann muss ich das mit allen machen. Das heißt, was wir jetzt geschafft haben, ist einfach wirklich dieses Level-Playing-Field ins Gesetz zu schreiben. Der Provider kann immer noch komplett neue Funktionalitäten, also wenn es wirklich so Dinge gibt, die es notwendig machen, dass man sich nicht im Best-Effort im Internet abhandeln kann, dann sind die immer noch möglich.
Ferne OPs.
Genau. Also alles, wo wirklich jetzt die diszerte Kapazitäten sind, Business, VPN und diese Sachen. Das sind Dinge, die natürlich immer noch gehen, die auch recht wenig mit dem Internet zu tun haben. Aber wir haben halt wirklich jetzt geschafft, ein Gesetz zu schreiben, das wasserdicht ist. Und das wird auch heißen, dass sich an der Landschaft der Produkte einiges ändern wird, sofern das denn in Kraft tritt. Wir müssen jetzt natürlich noch mal durch den Rat. Es ist jetzt noch nicht ein geltendes Gesetz, sondern wir haben jetzt sozusagen zwei von drei europäischen Institutionen passiert und der letzte Schritt ist wieder der Rat, genauso wie bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung auch. Die können sich halt Zeit lassen. Das sind die Staats- und Regierungschefs.
Zwei von drei, aber ich meine, du meinst ja, es ist die Kommission.
Genau, Kommission, Parlament und Rat.
Also du meinst, die Kommission hat sich jetzt auch diesen Gesetzentwurf angeschlossen?
Ja, das stimmt. Theoretisch können die natürlich in den Verhandlungen auch noch Nein sagen und sich zurückziehen, aber eigentlich passieren die Verhandlungen jetzt zwischen Parlament und Rat und die beiden müssen sich sozusagen auf einen Textentwurf einigen. Die Kommission hat dann eigentlich recht wenig Mitspracherecht. Theoretisch könnten sie Dinge zurückziehen und so, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das machen werden. Vor allem bei der Kommission, die wird jetzt auch neu gewählt und da ist dann auch unklar, wer die Nachfolger von Nelly Cruz annehmen wird, als Kommissarin fürs Digitale.
Ja, sag nochmal was zu Nelly Cruz. Sie war ja sehr beleidigt, hat dann in ihrer Ansprache in dem Parlament vor der Abstimmung sich beklagt, dass Lobbyisten diese Abstimmung hochstilisiert hätten zu einem Freiheit versus Tyrannei. Damit glaube ich bezog sie sich ziemlich klar auf euch.
Sie hat sogar gesagt, there are people talking about saving the Internet. Und sich irrsinnig eschöphiert darüber, dass es Kritik gibt an ihrem Entwurf. Und sie hat halt wirklich diese Änderungsanträge. Es ist ganz wichtig, sie hat diese Änderungsanträge 24 Stunden vor der Abstimmung, als den Killer für Innovation, für Wettbewerb bezeichnet, als ein Einfallstor für Kinderpornografie. Wenn das durchgeht, dann kann man nicht mehr effektiv gegen Kinderpornografie vorgehen im Internet. Das wäre ein total bürokratisches, unrealistisches Gefilde, was da jetzt beschlossen würde. Deswegen muss man ganz klar gegen diese Änderungsanträge sein. Nach der Abstimmung, 24 Stunden später, hat sie dem Parlament gratuliert für diesen wunderbaren Text, der jetzt die Zukunft Europas im Binnenmarkt stärken wird und der Netzneutralität garantiert und der Innovation steigern wird und Wettbewerb steigern wird. Die Frau hat echt in die unterste Schublade gegriffen. Ich meine, die hat Kinder da in ihren politischen Kampf mit hineingezogen. Es stimmt schon, wir haben da ja die Internetzensur rausbekommen. Wir haben diese freiwilligen Maßnahmen vom Provider, das steckt da so ein bisschen dahinter, dass ein Provider halt einen Gerichtsbeschluss braucht, damit er irgendwas zensieren kann. Das ist, was wir jetzt beschlossen haben und das ist auch, wozu wir stehen. Und was halt rausgeflogen ist, ist, dass ein Provider ohne Gesetz und ohne Gericht selber Dinge zensieren kann. Das ist aber schon vor Monaten rausgeflogen und da hat die Kommission nichts dazu gesagt. Sie hat das jetzt im letzten Moment, diese Karte gezogen und das zeigt, dass es halt überhaupt nicht um Inhalt geht, sondern nur um Polemik.
Das war aber noch ein Punkt, den wir genau in der letzten Woche schon angesprochen hatten, wo es nämlich um, wo wir uns ja sehr viel mit Netzsperren auseinandergesetzt haben, denn wenn ich das hier richtig sehe, sind Netzsperren damit auch erst mal vom Tisch oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Du brauchst einen Gerichtsbeschluss, aber mit Gerichtsbeschluss kannst du diese Dinge tun. Also wenn dann Richter eine Anordnung schreibt oder im gerichtenden Verfahren zu diesem Schluss kommt, dann kannst du durchaus auch im Netz zensieren, auch als Transitprovider, das heißt auch dieses EuGH-Urteil, das steht eigentlich nicht in Konflikt dazu. Das hilft uns nichts und das schadet uns nichts. Aber jetzt mal zum Beispiel, wenn du nur Gesetze hast, die Dinge zensieren wollen, ohne dass es da ein Gerichtsprozess dazu gibt, dann wäre das im Grunde nach diesem Gesetz eben draußen. Die Frage, ob das auch den Rat überlebt. Aber ich bin glücklich, dass wir es jetzt wirklich auf das niedrigste Niveau runtergegeben haben, weil wenn ein Gericht etwas entscheidet, man kann dann immer noch diskutieren, ob ein Transit-Provider, der jetzt nicht der Hoster ist, anfangen soll zu zensieren. Aber das ist eine andere Debatte. Die konnten wir im Rahmen dieser Verordnung leider nicht führen.
So, bei euch haben jetzt die Sektkocken geknallt, obwohl das noch durch den Rat muss. Was steht denn jetzt vor uns mit dieser Ratsache?
Ja, der Rat, der geht jetzt durch dieses Gesetz durch und da müssen die 28 Länder sich einigen. Das Problem beim Rat ist immer, dass er sehr intransparent ist, dass man da als zivilbevölkerung eigentlich recht wenig Einblicke hat in die Verhandlungen. Das ist beim Parlament ganz anders. Und ja, das wäre jetzt halt wirklich die Frage, was die zuständigen Ministerien und in manchen Fällen auch die Regulierungsbehörden des Landes für eine Meinung sich bilden zu dem Thema. Die arbeiten jetzt auch mal auf Basis des Kommissionsvorschlagers. Die wollen selber sozusagen zu ihrer Position kommen und wenn sie die haben, verhandeln sie mit dem Parlament und dann versucht man eben da Konsens zu finden. Dann kann es auch noch mal eine zweite und eine dritte Lesung geben, wo das Parlament wieder darüber abstimmt, ob es dem zustimmen kann. Und ja, wenn man da irgendwann mal zu einer Einigung kommt, dann hat man ein fertiges Gesetz und dann gilt in Europa Netzatualität. Schön wär's, gäbe es da Deadlines. Also der Rat macht das so, wenn ihm was nicht gefällt, dann nimmt das von der Tagesordnung. Dann ist es formal immer noch da und das Parlament hat vielleicht schon darüber entschieden, aber es ist halt nicht auf der Tagesordnung, das heißt, es wird nicht verhandelt, das heißt, es passiert nichts und dann passiert halt über Jahre nichts, bis es irgendwann einmal vom Tisch runter fällt. Das heißt, die Gefahr beim Rat ist immer, dass der einfach dadurch, dass er Dinge ignoriert, sie tötet. Das ist aber jetzt, nachdem wir jetzt zwei große netzpolitische Themen schon am Rat haben, nämlich eben die Datenschutz- Grundverordnung und Netzneutralität, finde ich auch, dass wir uns mal mehr Gedanken um den Rat machen müssen. Das fordert aber natürlich eine ganz andere Art von Aktivismus und von Zivilgesellschaft, weil das sind 28 Länder mit ganz unterschiedlichen Diskursen. Da sind wir jetzt auch noch am überlegen, was eine gute Strategie ist und vielleicht safe die Internet weiter als Plattform zu verwenden für diesen Prozess. Aber ja, das ist alles noch im Werden.
Im Prinzip müsste man dann quasi auf die nationalen Regierungen Einfluss nehmen und an der Stelle wäre es auch wichtig mehr noch, ich meine, EDRI ist ja eine europäische Organisation, aber nur in eingeschränktem Maße jetzt auch so eine Föderation von europäischen Aktivistengruppen, also die fördern und stehen ja teilweise auch aus diesen Gruppen, aber...
Also wir haben 35 Mitgliedsorganisationen in fast allen europäischen Ländern, also nicht nur aus Europa, wir haben auch die EFF aus den USA und Leute in der Türkei und sozusagen was nicht die Union ist, aber wir haben schon viele Mitglieder in den Ländern, die sich auch dann beschäftigen und die auch dann, wie zum Beispiel DigiGas, in Deutschland diese Themen sozusagen national bespielen. Und DigitalCourage und ich glaube, es gibt noch ein paar andere deutsche Mitglieder bei EDRI. Genau, der ZZZ, ganz wichtig ist ja auch Gründungsmitglied von EDRI. Und ja, also da gibt es so ein Netzwerk aus Nationalsstaaten, das man da jetzt aber auch mal aktivieren müsste dafür, um eben die nationalen Regierungen zu lobbyieren.
Aber das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Nummer, weil das natürlich dann quasi in jedem Land einen anderen Hebel erfordert.
Ja, und ganz andere Argumente und die Voraussetzungen sind halt auch andere. Also es gibt Länder, die haben ja so gut wie gar keine Netzertralitätsverletzungen, wie Österreich, wo obwohl es kein Gesetz gibt, die Regulierungsbehörde einfach genau hinschaut, dann gibt es Länder, die solche Gesetze haben, dann gibt es aber auch Länder, die sich gar nicht drum scheren, wie Großbritannien, die haben da so eine ganz komische freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung, die nicht funktioniert. Und es gibt ja auch Produkte in diesen Ländern, die schon gegen Netzertralität verstoßen, die dann verboten wird. Das heißt, da hat man halt einfach eine sehr diverse Situation, das ist aber immer das, was eigentlich diese europäische Debatte ausmacht, dass man irgendwie so diesen Konsens finden muss zwischen allen. Aber wichtig ist, das Europa-Parlament hat gestern das Prinzip Netzneutralität festgeschrieben und da wird es sehr schwierig davon abzuweichen. Also in dieser Verordnung sind ja auch noch andere Dinge drinnen, wie angeblich das Ende der Roaming-Gebühren, das ist eigentlich ein Etikettenschwindel, weil es wird so etwas wie Roaming-Gebühren geben, sie werden nur anders heißen, das sagt keiner dazu. Ich habe es mir jetzt nicht den letzten an den Detail angeschaut, aber es wurde da irgendwo mal in diesem Prozess, ich glaube im IMKO oder I3 Ausschuss, ich weiß nicht, woher das zustande kam, aber die haben da recht viel gedoktert an dem Teil, so dass es eine Fair Use-Klausel gibt, das heißt, du hast keine Roaming-Gebühren für ungefähr 35 Tage im Jahr und danach musst du eine nicht näher spezifizierte Gebühr zahlen, die der Provider dann einheben kann, die auch sehr groß sein kann und abhängig von deinem Telefon und Datenaufkommen und SMS aufkommen. Theoretisch könnten sie damit exakt wieder dieselben Gebühren einführen, die sie jetzt so ganz laut rausgestrichen haben. Also ja, da müsste man auch noch mal näher hinschauen. Aber wie gesagt, da habe ich mich auch nicht näher beschäftigt. Ich würde das mit Vorsicht genießen, wenn jetzt überall drinnen steht, die Wohmegebühren wurden abgeschafft. Also das ist wirklich sozusagen eher das populistische, die Karotte, mit der man das Parlament dazu gebracht hat, diese Verordnung zu verabschieden. Das müsste man sich aber wirklich mal jemanden von den Konsumentenschützern näher anschauen, was da drin steht.
Was mich noch mal interessieren würde, die jetzt in den letzten Wochen ja auch noch mal vielfältig gepriesene Plattformen, savetheinternet.eu, hast du da Einblicke darüber, wie sehr die jetzt wirklich genutzt wurde von Leuten?
Ja, also wir haben beim Faxtool, das Fax- und E-Mail-Tool haben wir irgendwie bei der Netzfreiheit gebaut am Anfang von der Kampagne und beim Faxtool habe ich Zahlen, das sind um die 29.000 Faxe, die da rausgegangen sind. Das ist sehr viel toter Baum. Da habe ich auch schon ganz nette Anekdoten gehört, wie wieder mit diesen Faxen umgegangen wurde und was, wie einfach kontinuierlich immer das Papier leer war im Drucker. Das hat gut funktioniert und dann haben wir beim Telefontool, es hat Lagrater Tür gemacht, die haben mir gestern gesagt, dass sie sogar mehr Anrufe hatten als zu Hochzeit von ACTA. Als ACTA im Plenum abgestimmt wurde, gab es ja auch schon dieses Telefontool, das Python von Lagrater Tür. Das haben wir hier auch wieder verwendet. Wir haben ACTA gesprengt in Zahlen, das fand ich auch sehr bemerkenswert. Bei den E-Mails wissen wir es nicht. Von den Besucherzahlen her waren wir, glaube ich, insgesamt, seit es die Kampagne gibt seit Dezember bei, glaube ich, 860.000 Pageviews, wo ich aber keine Relation dazu habe, ob das jetzt besonders viel oder wenig ist.
Na gut, man kann jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass das Tool ignoriert worden ist. Also es scheint schon einen sehr signifikanten Beitrag geleistet zu haben. Und damit haben sozusagen auch die Leute einen signifikanten Beitrag geleistet. 29.000 Faxe klingt für mich jetzt nicht wenig. Na gut, es wird sich auch ein paar Faxgeräte verteilt haben. Ich weiß nicht, auf wie viele Faxgeräte sich Maximale hat verteilen können.
Aber ja, wir hatten einen sehr freundlichen Provider aus Österreich, KappaNet, und die haben uns da so ein S7 Gateway zur Verfügung gestellt, mit dem wir das umsetzen konnten. Auch noch mal Dank dafür, weil die haben die Kosten übernommen von diesen 29.000 Faxen. Und ja, also das war sicherlich, den Leuten solche Tools in die Hand zu geben, dass sie das Motto von der Seite war ja auch, wer dein eigener Lobby ist, dass sie sich zu Wort melden können und ausdrücken können, dass ihnen dieses Thema wichtig ist. Das ist schon immer noch unsere Superwaffe, dass wir halt einfach die Öffentlichkeit auf unserer Seite haben und dass wir Menschen ermöglichen, einfach direkt in Kontakt zu treten mit der Politik. Also, das hätten wir auch überhaupt nicht geschafft, hätten wir nicht so viele Leute gehabt, denen das Thema wichtig ist und die auch wirklich was dafür tun. Das ist dann auch vor allem bei den liberalen Abgeordneten angekommen. Da habe ich auch Geschichten gehört, dass die dann halt einfach diese Telefonanrufe mit Leuten, denen das Thema urwichtig ist, das ist für die halt auch etwas, das nicht ins Tagesgeschäft hineinpasst. Dass dann auf einmal irgendein beliebiger Bürger anruft und sich meldet und sagt so, mir ist das so wichtig und du musst hier unbedingt was machen, das sind die nicht gewohnt.
Ja und jetzt?
Ja, jetzt war es irgendwie mal gut so weit. Ich gehe wieder zurück nach Österreich. Und wir haben ja schon nächste Woche wieder das nächste Ding, da ist ja das Urteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Da werde ich auch mitarbeiten. Ich will aber noch gerne irgendwie auf ein anderes Thema zu sprechen kommen, nämlich wenn wir uns jetzt mal anschauen, was wir heute, was wir gestern geschaffen haben, dann hat man schon irgendwie gemerkt, dass so seit Akta was passiert ist im Europaparlament. Dass von den netzpolitischen Themen wir schon auf der europäischen Ebene wahnsinnig viel bewegen können. Und wir haben jetzt halt bald Europawahl und das wäre eigentlich diese Chance, diese netzpolitischen Potenziale noch mehr Bedeutung zu verleihen und da auch noch mal in der Wahl darauf hinzuweisen, weil nirgends woanders sind die Kandidaten so leicht erreichbar wie jetzt und deswegen haben wir diese WePromise.eu-Kampagne schnell erklärt, das ist so die Idee eines beidseitigen Versprechens, dass die Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten versprechen können, dass sie eine Charter von zehn digitalen Grundrechten unterstützen werden, dass sie in ihrem Mandat, wenn sie gewählt werden im Parlament, nicht zum Beispiel gegen eine anlachslose Vollüberwachung stimmen und dass sie Copyright reformieren, sich für Netzautorität einsetzen und all diese Dinge. Also da haben wir die zehn wichtigsten netzpolitischen Punkte zusammengesammelt und auf der anderen Seite des Versprechens stehen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger, die dort mit diesem Versprechen eben wie in einer Petition angeben können, dass sie einen Kandidaten wählen werden, der diese zehn Prinzipien unterstützt. Und wenn man auf netzpolitik.org geht, dann findet man das. Wenn man auf WePromise.eu geht, dann findet man das. Und die Kandidaten, die das schon unterstützt haben und auch so Videobotschaften von denen, wo man dann selber beurteilen kann, ob man denen das glaubt. Und wir finden halt wirklich, dass das jetzt eigentlich der nächste Schritt sein müsste. Dass man sich anschaut, was in den nächsten fünf Jahren im Europaparlament passiert. Wir haben definitiv mal die zweite Lesung von der Datenschutzverordnung und von Netzneutralität, damit wir das wirklich unter Dach und Fach bekommen brauchen wir da wieder eine Mehrheit in der Abstimmung, die für diese Themen ist. Es wird eine riesige Copyright-Reform geben. Nach dieser Konsultation, die die Kommission gemacht hat, mit über 11.000 Antworten, müssen die jetzt endlich Urheberrecht anpacken und hoffentlich machen sie mal irgendwie ein Update, das der Realität entspricht und das gesetzennäher an die Lebensrealität rückt. Und ganz wichtig, je nachdem wie das Urteil nächste Woche ausfällt, aber ich gehe stark davon aus, dass das nächste Parlament über die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie abstimmen wird. Und das ist für Deutschland wahrscheinlich eines der wichtigsten Themen. Weil meine Vermutung ist, dass nächste Woche der EGH was ähnliches sagt wie der deutsche Verfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe, dass er sagt, gut, diese Richtlinie ist verfassungswidrig, aber theoretisch könnte man so eine Überwachungsmaßnahme machen, wenn ABCDE. Und dann legt er ein Ablaufdatum auf diese Richtlinie und sagt, die tritt mit 1.1.2015 außer Kraft und bis dahin muss das repariert werden und eine neue Richtlinie kommen. Das ist ein sehr wahrscheinliches Szenario und das heißt, das muss durch das Parlament und das heißt, wir haben eine politische Debatte über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und vielleicht können wir endlich dieses Übel an der Wurzel packen und beseitigen.
19 potenzielle Europawahlkandidatinnen aus Deutschland haben jetzt hier dieser ganzen Geschichte schon zugestimmt. Ich sage mal aus dem üblichen verdächtigen Spektrum, also grün, linke, Piraten vor allem, eine Frau noch von der SPD. Wie seid ihr da dran? Wie werden die angesprochen?
Das ist eigentlich auch so was, wo Leute in den Mitgliedstaaten aktiv werden können. Es gibt eine Mailingliste, da kann man sich subscriben. Es gibt da ganz viele ausgearbeitete Dokumente, die man den Leuten schicken kann und wir würden halt eigentlich gerne, dass da Leute in den 28 EU-Staaten ihre Kandidaten kontaktieren, weil wenn wir das aus Brüssel machen, dann wirkt das ein bisschen aufgesetzt. Wir sind nicht die Leute, die die wählen werden. Wir wollen, dass die Bürger in den Ländern hergehen und sagen, diese zehn Punkte sind wichtig, ich wollte das unterstützen. Das ist das, worzu man sich verpflichtet. Die müssen da auch wirklich Dokument unterschreiben und uns unterschrieben, zurückscannen oder schicken, damit wir das annehmen. Das heißt, das hat einen offiziellen Charakter und damit diese Zahl mehr wird. Ich glaube, in Deutschland sind es wirklich wahnsinnig viele Kandidaten. Ich glaube, so pro Partei 100 und da müsste man noch viel mehr anschreiben und die Kandidaten darauf hinweisen, dass sie diese Charter doch unterstützen sollen. Und dann kann man auch sehr schön sehen vor der Wahl, wer wird jetzt sich netzpolitisch in ordentlich verhalten im nächsten Parlament und und wem ist das Thema sowieso egal.
Ja, super Sache. Ich finde das gut. Ich habe überhaupt das Gefühl, dass die topleveldomain.eu so ein Petitionspool zu werden scheint. Mehr politischen Aktivismus unter.eu gesehen als irgendwas anderes, aber das soll mir recht sein. Linus, hast du noch was anzumerken? Sonst müssen wir nämlich hier glaube ich unseren Kandidaten, Kandidat ist er ja nicht, aber unseren Aktivisten müssen wir jetzt mal langsam wieder dem Aktivismus überlassen, der hat nämlich noch Termine.
Termine und er war heute sehr früh auf, was ich nicht gedacht hätte. Sehr zu erwarten gewesen, dass du entweder noch schläfst oder betrunken bist.
Vielleicht noch mal zum Schluss, die Stimmung denke ich mal ist so generell gut bei EDRI.?
Ja, also wir haben gestern gefeiert. Das hat auch gleich nach der Abstimmung angefangen und ist dann bis in die Nacht hineingegangen. Ich bin es nur gewohnt, inzwischen mit wahnsinnig wenig Schlaf aufzukommen. Das ist der Grund, warum ich jetzt noch irgendwie vor dem Mikrofon bin. Und ja, also das wird dann auch gefeiert. Also ich meine EDRI., das muss man vielleicht auch sagen. Also EDRI arbeitet an dem Thema seit fünf Jahren. Seit Kommissionspräsidenten Cruz ins Amt gekommen ist, arbeitet EDRI an dem Thema Netzautorität und drängt auf genau so eine Verordnung, wie sie heute beschlossen wurde, wie sie gestern beschlossen wurden. Ich bin immer noch im Kopf. Ja, also auch Access Now, die Organisation, die mit unserem Büro setzt, hat irrsinnig viel dran gearbeitet und la Quadratür, die net und Bits zufrieden und DigiGas und Netzfreiheit, all denen ist zu danken. Und das ist halt wirklich so von zivilgesellschaftlicher Seite wirklich der Erfolg von ganz vielen, die über lange Zeit das zum Thema gemacht haben. Also man stelle sich vor, es gäbe keine Zivilgesellschaft für dieses Thema. Wir würden nicht mal drüber reden und ohne einem Brüsseler Büro, in dem dieser Aktivismus und dieser Lobbyismus vor allem passieren kann, wären wir heute nicht da, wo wir sind. Also Edre ist eine, ich war noch nie so überzeugt von der Notwendigkeit einer Organisation, wie dieser, weil die einfach so einen wahnsinnig großen Unterschied macht mit den unheimlich kleinen Ressourcen, die wir eigentlich haben. Also ich bin großer Fan von Edre geworden, seit ich hier arbeite. Das sage ich nicht nur, weil die mein Gehalt bezahlen.
Senden sie jetzt eine SMS mit dem Wort. Thomas, herzlichen Dank, hast du gut gemacht.
Genau, wir sind stolz auf euch und feiert noch das Wochenende durch, aber dann wieder an die Arbeit.
Ja, gut, euch noch eine gute Sendung und ja, auf bald.
Herzlichen Dank, Thomas.
So, weiter geht's.
Das nächste Thema hat Thomas gerade schon quasi angekündigt.
Nämlich Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Die USA downgraden ihre Vollüberwachung der Telefonmetadaten. Wir haben das schon vor einiger Zeit angesprochen, dass sie das vorhaben. Also im Detail hatte ich das schon mal erklärt. Nämlich, dass sie sagen, wir wollen keine zentrale Vorratsdatenspeicherung bei der Regierung mehr, sondern eine dezentrale beim Provider. Der Zugriff auf diese Daten soll der Regierung und ihren Strafverfolgungsorganen nur möglich sein unter Richtervorbehalt und die Daten, die dort vorgehalten werden, sollen auch nicht viele Jahre umfassen, sondern nur 18 Monate. Nur in Ausnahmefällen weichen wir von dem Richtervorbehalt ab. Und dann war auch diese schöne Sache drin, dass man nur zwei Hops von der Zielperson sich bewegen darf, statt drei oder vier. Also wer sich schon mal mit Binärbäumen auseinandergesetzt hat, weiß, wie viel man da dann immer noch, wie viele Personen aus dem Umfeld der Zielperson man dann immer noch abschnorcheln darf. Aber eben, es sind sehr viel weniger als bisher, denn es gab bei ihnen bisher keine Regulation und deswegen haben sie einfach immer alles gehabt und alles gemacht.
Sie haben so ein bisschen den Anschein erweckt, als hätten sie nur Freund eines Freundes eines Freundes und jetzt lassen sie sozusagen den letzten Freund weg, wo ja dann immer noch genug Freunde übrig bleiben. Letztlich ist es natürlich auch vollkommen unklar, ob das überhaupt so gewährleistet werden kann. Was halt das Herunterfahren des Speichers betrifft. Ich frage mich, was die Motivation dazu war. Ich meine, vielleicht haben sie auch einfach gesehen, das kostet uns sowieso alles viel zu viel Geld. Es ist ja viel besser, wenn wir das alles outsourcen und dann lassen wir das die Unternehmen machen. Letztlich dasselbe Modell, wie man das eben hier auch in Deutschland für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung anstrebt, zumindest in etwas extremeren politischen Flügel, auch immer mit dieser Argumentation. Das sei ja auch alles gar nicht so schlimm, weil der Staat würde ja gar nicht speichern, sondern wir lassen ja speichern.
Und deshalb halte ich das auch für so erwähnenswert, denn die downgraden auf 18 Monate Vorratsdatenspeicherung nach ziemlich genau dem Modell, wie es in Deutschland vorgesehen ist. Und ich weiß nicht, was mit diesen diese Hops, wie das in Deutschland dann wäre. Da bin ich nicht genau auf dem Laufenden, wie jetzt momentan sich die Sicherheitsbehörden eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gerade ausmalen.
Ich meine, wenn es dann die Telekommunikationsfirmen auf Vorrat machen, spielen die Hops ja gar keine Rolle mehr, weil dann werden ja wiederum alle gespeichert.
Gespeichert sowieso, es geht ja um den Zugriff. Das Ding ist halt, also ich meine, diese Hops, du definierst sie, solange du mindestens einen Hop dir definieren darfst. Den hast du ja per se bei der Kommunikation, wird einfach der Kommunikationspartner zu Zielpersonen. Dann kannst du ja von da aus weitermachen. Also, das heißt, wenn du, also diese diese Definition von zwei oder drei Hops ist halt totaler Vierlefanz. Weil dann machst du halt, wie gesagt, einfach die nächste Person wieder zur Zielperson und du darfst noch mal zweimal würfeln. Warum ich das erwähne, ist, weil das die erste wirklich handfeste Reaktion der USA ist auf diese gesamten Snowden-Enthüllungen und weil sogar Edward Snowden jetzt irgendwie sich zu Wort gemeldet hat und gesagt hat, find er gut.
Ja, das fand ich schon ein bisschen bemerkenswert, dass er sich da so so früh aus der Deckung gewagt hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Interesse daran hat, frühzeitig jetzt so bei den ersten halbwegs akzeptablen Zugeständnissen gleich gute Mine zum bösen Spiel zu machen. Keine Ahnung. Mir erscheint das ein bisschen früh, weil es ist ja in dem Sinne auch noch gar nichts passiert.
Also ich habe im amerikanischen, englischsprachigen Sprachraum, wird diese Nachricht tatsächlich als ein enormer Erfolg gewertet. Sogar die ACLU und so äußern sich alle relativ positiv darüber und sind begeistert. Also geht man echt davon aus, dass er sagt, da wird der Edward Snowden aber jetzt mal wirklich eine Flasche Sekt aufgemacht haben, ähnlich wie der Thomas jetzt.
Verstaunlich.
Also mal zur Ein-Nordung oder wie man das immer sagt.
Ja, da werden uns unsere deutschen Politiker bestimmt bald erzählen, wie wir sogar die freiheitsliebenden Nationen USA bei der Einführung einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung nach deutschem Vorbild gejubelt haben. Ja, na hurra.
Und dann kann man, also das ist echt mal, ich bin mal gespannt, wohin das führt.
Das ist sozusagen die Einführung des deutschen Reinheitsgebots in der Überwachung.
Ja, so in der Art. Ich habe keine Ahnung, dass das deutsche Reinheitsgebot von 2009. Da gibt es noch einige kleinere Randmeldungen, die ich nur so immer zur allgemeinen Erheiterung mit aufnehmen möchte. Also es wird dann gesagt, ja und der NSA hat also mehr als 300 Berichte über Angela Merkel angefertigt. Okay. Dann hat aber der US-Geheimdienstdirektor, unser Herr Klepper, die Ausforschung von US-Bürgern eingestanden. Von US-Bürgern ausgestanden. Eigentlich meine Güte.
Ja, es war ein Wunder, dass du so früh aufgewacht bist.
Ja, das ist echt ein Wunder, dass ich so früh noch aufgewacht bin. Also er hat eingestanden, dass US-Bürger ausgeforscht worden sein mögen.
Also sie haben jetzt zugegeben, was sie sowieso nicht mehr erfolgreich dementieren können.
Genau, im Rahmen ihrer 51-Prozent-Regel. Das war ja ganz zu Anfang. Da erinnert man sich ja gerade dran, dass sie gesagt haben, wenn sich der Analyst zu 51 Prozent sicher ist, dass die Person kein Amerikaner ist, dann darf sie auf die Daten zugreifen. Also, super, großartig. Ja, also in den USA tut sich auf jeden Fall was. Und was sich da auch wieder abzeichnet, ist dieses, was wir ja auch alle schon kennen. Ich hatte das am Anfang dieser ganzen Snowden-Sachen auch schon immer genannt, dass ja selbst die US-Geheimdienst-Aussteiger vor Snowden sich irgendwie auf Veranstaltungen stellen und dir einen erzählen von Americans don't spy on Americans. Ja, also das ist für die jetzt der große Skandal. Und da haben sie jetzt offensichtlich Schritte eingeleitet, interessant zu sehen, wie sich das weiterentwickelt.
Ja, das ist ja immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Ich meine, wenn man sich schon amerikanische Sportveranstaltungen anschaut, wo dann von World Series die Rede ist, weil sowohl östliche als auch westliche amerikanische Staaten daran teilnehmen können, dann hat man immer wieder so das Gefühl, dass so diese Wahrnehmung einer Weltproblematik dann doch immer sehr lokal ist. Aber ich will jetzt hier kein weiteres Bashing betreiben. Wir nehmen jetzt einfach erstmal zur Kenntnis. Nach einem Jahr hat das Ganze zumindest so weit Auswirkungen, dass es Ankündigungen gibt, die Methoden zu ändern. Ja, das ist ja schon mal nicht nichts. Da ist jetzt auch noch nichts passiert. Und ob man das nun glaubt, dass das auch so sein wird, das steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Ich hätte da persönlich eher, würde mich da eher sehr zurückhaltend äußern, was sie jetzt ankündigen und was sie dann tatsächlich tun. Man kann ihnen ja eigentlich gar nichts mehr glauben. Also ich weiß nicht, wo die Legitimation jetzt noch sich raus ableiten lassen sollte, dass man das für bare Münze nimmt.
Was ja am Ende dann das Problem ist bei so einer Vorratsdatensprechung, wenn man sagt, okay, die Daten sind beim Provider und der muss die auf Nachfrage herausgeben, ist das dann natürlich der Einwand kommen wird? Naja, aber dann weiß der Provider ja, wen wir überwachen. Und dann kommt man ja an die Lösung, die ja auch in Deutschland ganz gerne eingebracht wird. Okay, da gibt es natürlich jetzt nochmal den Unterschied zwischen Geheimdienst und Strafverfolgungsbehörden. Aber damit die deutschen Dienstanbieter nichts sehen, worauf die zugreifenden Behörden zugreifen, haben die einfach mal Grundzugriff auf alles, was man ja auch tatsächlich, also aus der Hinsicht tatsächlich verteidigen könnte. Denn das Problem der Strafvereitlungsmöglichkeiten wäre ja schon gegeben. Also wenn, sagen wir mal, ich wäre bei der deutschen Telekom derjenige, der die Datenanfragen entgegen nimmt, dann hätte ich ein sehr interessantes Nebengeschäft, Leuten zu sagen, pass mal auf, das kostet übrigens 50 Euro im Monat, dass ich dir Bescheid sage, sobald hier irgendeine Anfrage nach deinen Daten eingeht, damit du weißt, du musst das Land verlassen. Oder zum Beispiel, ich meine, Innenminister werden ja wird ja nachgesagt, dass die sowas teilweise auch machen, sogar ohne, dass sie Geld dafür bekommen. Aber der Verdacht steht ja im Raum, dass das passieren wird. Also mal gucken, wie sie es am Ende ausgestalten. Ich finde es nur sehr schön, dass Edward Snowden eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung dann als zugestellten, nennenswertes Entgegenkommen oder was wertet.
Ja, also ich habe auch...
Werdet ja auch einfach Lust, irgendwann nochmal seine Eltern zu sehen.
Ja, ich denke, er ist jetzt auch so dermaßen zum Messias der Freiheit hochgebetet worden, dass in gewisser Hinsicht zwangsläufig wohl irgendwann sich auch nochmal so eine Ernüchterung einstellen wird. Und das könnte durchaus sein, dass die genau zu dem Zeitpunkt stattfindet. Vielleicht zeichnet sich das jetzt auch schon ab. Wo dann klar wird, dass auch er, wenn auch aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen, dann irgendwie mit der Rettung der USA auch zufrieden ist. Und dass er jetzt so around the world gefeiert wird und irgendwie in Brasilien, Deutschland zumindest einen Teil dann schon zu so einem Volkshelden hochstilisiert wird. Dass das auch eine Rolle ist, die er so weder annehmen will noch kann noch, ja, vielleicht auch wird. Ich sage nicht, dass es wird zu kommen. Ich sage nur, darauf muss man sich auf jeden Fall auch einstellen, weil das ist natürlich jetzt auch alles schon ein ziemlich übertriebener Hype. Man hat sozusagen das Gefühl, mit ihm so eine Allianz zu haben für alle irgendwie erdenklichen politischen Vorschläge, die sich potentiell eben auch gegen die USA richten, sei es aus einem falsch verstandenen Anti-Amerikanismus oder aus ganz normalen nationalen Interessen heraus, also auch nationalen Interessen einer Freiheitsbewegung unter Umständen, die dann irgendwann verstellen darf. Da macht er dann halt auch nicht mit. Weil das ist es nicht, worum es ihm ging. Oder um es mal vielleicht etwas polemischer zu sagen, man muss sich auch klarmachen, dieser Typ war beim Geheimdienst. Also ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass er der geborene Freiheitskämpfer mit dem Flammenschwert gegen die großen Mächte der Welt geboren wurde, sondern er war halt beim Geheimdienst und hat halt irgendwie Leute abgehört. Das war halt irgendwie sein Job. Aber an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt hat er dann einfach gesehen, so na ja, also das geht mir jetzt eigentlich zu weit.
Naja, er hat aber schon auch ein ganz großes Opfer dafür erbracht, dass ihm das ein bisschen zu weit geht.
Wie gesagt, es war eine polemische, einfach nur, um vielleicht mal einen anderen Blick gewinnen zu können und dass man nicht immer so verhaftet ist in so einer gottgleichen Behandlung seiner Person. Er hat ja auf jeden Fall seine Verdienste und alles ist super. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich noch zu früh darüber nachzudenken, einen deutschen Feiertag nach ihm einzurichten.
Deutscher Feiertag war übrigens am 30.3. Ja, da war ein Feiertag. Da wurde E-Mail made in Germany endlich umgesetzt. Der deutsche E-Mail-Tag. Am 9. August 2013 haben sie das angekündigt, dass sie jetzt die Transportverschlüsselung für E-Mails einschalten. Tag der Deutschen Sicherheit. Am 9. August 2013 haben sie angekündigt, wir machen jetzt Transportverschlüsselung bei E-Mails. Ich hatte das ja auch kritisiert, dann ausführlich. Im Dezember hatte ich ja dann festgestellt, eher durch Zufall, dass sie es eben nicht tun. Dass sie also die Verschlüsselung genau nicht erzwingen. Das heißt, die Änderung, die bis dahin nur war, war, dass sie zwischen ihren E-Mails-Servern nicht mehr unverschlüsselt die E-Mails durch das Internet blasen, aber ihre Nutzer eben selber noch nicht schützen. Also wer ist denn sie jetzt? Deutsche Telekom, United Internet, also Freenet, GMX, web.de und T-Mobile.
Und die haben alle am gleichen Tag angefangen damit?
Ich glaube, dass sie es tatsächlich alle an einem Tag gemacht haben, ja. Also ich habe es jetzt, die Meldung betraf alle und war am gleichen Tag. Und ich habe es jetzt gerade nochmal ausprobiert, man bekommt, wenn man jetzt unverschlüsselt auf seine E-Mails zugreift, kriegt man eine Standard-Antwort, also eine E-Mail. Man hat dann nur eine E-Mail und in der steht drin, wie man sein Postfach auf Verschlüsselung umstellt und dass man unverschlüsselt sein auf seine E-Mails nicht mehr zugreifen kann.
Also ist jetzt schon jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht mehr möglich, unverschlüsselt auf die eigene Mailbox zuzugreifen, weil ich könnte dir gar nicht vorstellen, dass es so kurzer Zeit ist.
Es gibt halt noch ein kleines Problem, was sie glaube ich nicht ganz bedacht haben, ist, dass die Nutzer natürlich trotzdem die ganze Zeit automatisch, also so wie sie es jetzt gelöst haben, sie geben dir also, du loggst dich ein und sie antworten dir mit dieser, sie fälschen quasi deinen Posteingang, indem sie dir eine E-Mail da reinlegen, wo drin steht, du kannst deine E-Mail nicht mehr abholen. Das so macht sie Deutsche Telekom.
Verstehe.
Das Problem ist natürlich, zu dem Zeitpunkt hat der Nutzer ja schon dann sein Passwort geschickt. Das heißt, der Abhörende kennt an der Stelle natürlich auch das Kennwort schon und kann dann halt auf die verschlüsselte Verbindung umsteigen und die E-Mail abholen. Also es gibt da immer noch ein Leak.
Na gut, die Frage ist natürlich, ob sie vielleicht in einem zweiten Schritt auch noch ein neues Passwort erzwingen.
Ne, das war eventuell auch eine falsche Behauptung gerade von mir gewesen, weil ich sehe hier nicht, dass sie nach dem Passwort fragen. Also auf jeden Fall, sie haben es jetzt wenigstens mal gemacht. Wunderbar, also viele Monate später. Das ist auf jeden Fall jetzt der Schritt, der dann am 9. August notwendig gewesen wäre. Hier bei GMX melde ich mich dann noch mit Passwort an, kriege dann aber nichts. Ja, also sie haben es auf jeden Fall jetzt gemacht. So, man kann erstmal unverschlüsset, bekommt man keine E-Mails mehr und dadurch erzwingen sie natürlich jetzt auch, dass die Nutzer dann jetzt alle ihre E-Mail-Programme, die noch über sind, umstellen müssen. Das heißt, ja, sie haben jetzt ihr Versprechen eingelöst, mit dem sie letztes Jahr im Sommer Werbung gemacht haben. Dann gibt es ja sowieso, das habe ich gestern durch Zufall gesehen, irgendwie es wurden mal wieder 18 Millionen E-Mail-Passwörter irgendwie gefunden. Das ist ja inzwischen nichts Neues mehr, dass so was passiert.
Die lagen mal wieder irgendwo rum. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ist, ist das so ein bisschen, haben die beim BSI da so eine Babyklappe für Passwörter?
Ich glaube, die googeln selber.
Finden die dann einfach.
Das BSI googelt selber, handgegoogelt. Also genau durch so was, also 18 Millionen Passwörter, da brauchst du schon ein großes Botnet oder große E-Mail-Provider, die unverschüssete Verbindungen zulassen. Sonst kriegst du die nicht. Aber was ich sehr schön fand, es gab in den letzten Wochen eine Meldung, da hat ein Blogger aus einer anonymen Quelle etwas bekommen. Ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig erkenne, ein Stück Software von einer internen Microsoft-Quelle. Also Blogger bekommt aus einer anonymen Quelle ein Stück Software. Und Blogger sagt, ah, okay, im Rahmen meiner journalistischen Tätigkeit möchte ich jetzt bei Microsoft verifizieren, dass das, was ich hier bekommen habe, auch tatsächlich von Ihnen ist. Also wende ich mich mal an Microsoft und sage, schaut mal, Freunde, ich habe hier das und das. Ist das euch gestohlen worden? Ich würde gerne einen Artikel drüber schreiben. Und Microsoft sagt, wie ist denn die E-Mail-Adresse von dem? lalala.at.hotmail.com. Die liegt doch bei uns.
Also dieser Blogger hat Microsoft die E-Mail-Adresse gegeben, nicht die Software, die zugeschickt wurde.
Nein, der Blogger hat Microsoft seine E-Mail-Adresse offenbart, beziehungsweise seine eigene Identität, die bei Microsoft gesagt hat, jetzt schauen wir doch mal, was wir von einem guten Blogger bei uns auf den Servern haben und was der mit seinem MSN-Messenger und mit seinem Hotmail und was er sonst alles bei uns für Dienste nutzt, so geschrieben hat.
Dieser Lika war auch so klug an eine Microsoft-Adresse zu sein.
Das ist jetzt erstmal völlig egal. Der Punkt ist nicht, wer hier schlau war. Der Punkt ist, dass Microsoft diesen Blogger auf dessen E-Mail zugegriffen hat. Welche Erkenntnis sie daraus gewonnen haben, halte ich an der Stelle erstmal für völlig egal. Und sie sagen, also das finde ich genau das schöne Ding, Microsofts AGB erlauben es Microsoft Informationen in den Accounts, die in ihren Kommunikationsdiensten gespeichert sind, anzuschauen. Zum Beispiel E-Mail, Bulletin Board, Chat Areas, News Groups und so weiter. File-Cabinets, also alles, was du denen gibst oder was du durch sie kommunizierst, haben sie laut ihren AGBs die Erlaubnis, reinzuschauen. Kurz darauf meldet sich ein anderer Blogger zu Wort, der, ich glaube, jetzt fällt mir gerade nicht ein, für welche Plattform der geschrieben hat, zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil es schon etwas her war, ich glaube CNET oder so, dem das gleiche oder ein ähnlicher Sachverhalt mit Gmail passiert ist. Das heißt, die haben halt, wenn es ihre eigenen Unternehmensinteressen betrifft, da brauchen sie natürlich auch keinen Richter vorbehalten, weil das hast du denen in den AGBs schon zugestimmt, dass sie deine E-Mails lesen dürfen.
Da schauen sie dann einfach mal rein und dann sind sie auch diesem Vogel, glaube ich, nachgegangen, der dieses Leak geschickt hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie den dann in der Folge auch zur Anzeige gebracht haben.
Dessen bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, weil ich mich schon an der Stelle, dass sie überhaupt reingeschaut haben, so auffällig habe.
Das hat natürlich eine Menge Wind gemacht und Microsoft hat mittlerweile ja auch zurückgerodert und bekannt gegeben, dass sie das fortan nicht mehr tun wollen würden. Da kann man natürlich jetzt vollsten vertrauens sein. Also ich würde sagen, ich spreche Microsoft mein vollstes Vertrauen aus in dieser Hinsicht.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also das kann man hier schon mal feststellen. Ja, da stehen sie ein bisschen doof da. Das haben sie dann irgendwie auch gemerkt, dass das quasi nicht so der beste Weg war. Andererseits, und darauf wollte ich eigentlich nur hinaus, Microsoft Code leaken und das irgendwie an jemanden zu schicken, der eine Microsoft-Mail-Adresse hat, ist auch schon so ein bisschen ein Antrag für einen Darwin Award.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob die Person auch tatsächlich dahin gemailt hat, denn gesendet wurde es halt von einer ad-mail.ru-Email-Adresse, das ist in der Regel, wenn ein Punkt ru dran ist, kannst du dir relativ sicher sein, dass deine Identität halbwegs geschützt ist. Dann gab es aber auch noch diese Instant-Message-Kommunikation. Ich finde es, wie gesagt, der genaue Hintergrund, den halte ich gar nicht für so entscheidend. Der Punkt ist, dass Microsoft nach eigenem Ermessen dort in den E-Mails einer journalistisch tätigen Person Nachforschung angestellt hat und dass die, wenn man sich darüber nachdenkt, wie du gerade schon sagst, an den Obstsäckerwägungen der beiden, kann man durchaus Kritik üben. Und das zeigt, dass es selbstverständlich ist, dass die da reinschauen. Das finde ich jetzt noch nicht mal. Natürlich machst du das. Du hast doch nicht deinen E-Mails-Server stehen, wo du die halbe Welt darauf kommunizierst und lässt dir von irgendeinem auf der Nase rumtanzen, der deine E-Mail bei dir hostet. Also natürlich nicht.
Jetzt haben sie auf jeden Fall hoch und heilig gespornen, dass sie in solchen Fällen das an die Behörden weitergeben würden.
Mit dem gleichen Ergebnis. Einen Tag Bearbeitungszeit. Lieber Richter, erlaub uns doch mal bitte, unsere eigene Festplatte zu legen. Hier kurz in unsere eigene Festplatte zu gucken. Quatsch. Also natürlich machen die das.
Selbstverständlich machen die das.
Nee, das soll es für heute sein. Wir haben ja gute Nachrichten und die schlechten...
Das wollen wir jetzt nicht so verwässern.
Genau, wir wollen die Freude nicht verwässern. Wir sind ja auch beide erkennbar müde heute.
Ja, insofern machen wir hier mal einen Strich unter die Sendung. Das war's. Logbuch Netzpolitik 98, die 100 Naht.
Die 100 Naht.
Ja, wir grübeln, was wir da machen. Ihr braucht uns keine Vorschläge zu schicken.
Hat auch niemand. Wir haben keine Vorschläge bekommen, finde ich.
Nee, ich meine, jetzt könnte es natürlich losgehen, wenn wir nicht aufpassen.
Aber ich sage schon, wir brauchen eigentlich keine Vorschläge, weil wir haben schon einen.
Genau. Und das kommt dann alles demnächst auf euch zu. Bis dahin wünschen wir euch noch viel Spaß am Netz, am Gerät.